none of this even if he's convicted and
sent to prison that won't affect his
ability to run he could run from prison
it's a great day for America it's a
great day for freedom
the very basic Cliff Notes version is he
is accused of paying via Michael Cohen
his then lawyer a Jewish lawyer good boy
why'd you have to say that he's a lawyer
of course he's just a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars into Stormy Daniels yep
who's not a model she's in fact a porn
star yeah exactly to keep her quiet in
order that she didn't reveal their fair
that she had with him in 2006. shortly
after his wife Melania gave birth to
their child yeah and that's the
allegation and there is evidence that
that is what happened Trump initially
denied that this payment was made then
he his team confirmed that they were
aware of it and Michael Cohen made the
payment and then got a reimbursement
back from the Trump campaign after the
election they wrote off a hush money
payment yeah porn star is a business
expense and that is busy but hang on a
second couldn't you argue legitimately
it is a business expense how is that a
business it's PR mate is PR it's a PR
payment it's pretty but look it's public
relations and what you do you don't
think it was done in private mate yeah
but it's very private relations yeah but
it's a public relations I mean she does
Private relations in public that's the
nature of her job mate but it is a
public relations exercise on behalf of
trump can't you argue that
I think comedically you could uh I don't
think I would work in the New York Court
in a tournament gift room where
companies promote their products a
pornography studio called wicked
pictures and set up a photo booth and
was handing out goodie bags of DVDs this
is a weirdest golf tournament I've ever
heard in my life the actresses included
louisiana-born Stephanie Clifford a
rising Los angeles-based star in the
porn industry who was known by her
professional name Stormy Daniels in a
book she claimed Mr Trump dressed in a
black in black single pajamas was
interested in how profitable her
pornographic films were and then she
claimed they had sex I mean that is the
most believable drop story ever how much
money do you make let's have sex I think
if you were going to prosecute a
president you best make damn sure that
you've got a rock solid cave case and
what you're Prosecuting them for is
incredibly serious John Poulter says
trigonometry it's the chosen way of
stopping him running actually it's not
he could none of the this even if he's
convicted and sent to prison that won't
affect his ability to run he could run
from prison
and if he goes to prison he you have you
have you have every reason to believe
that you will run imagine him running
from prison do you know what
that will probably happen that probably
will happen this is how mental
incredible this is how mental this world
now is you know what I would love to see
that
the first president to win from jail
yeah it's a great day for America it's a
great day for freedom
[__] get back in yourself yeah
yeah we're gonna build a wall not here
but outside we're gonna break down the
wall first
you mentioning that wolves can't contain
me he'll be saying something I don't
know if he's elected yeah he could
pardon himself laughs
you know what this is why in spite of
everything I kind of like Trump he is
the banter president yes you ignore the
fact that he's taken America to the
British Civil War apart from that he's
great he's [__] hilarious
look the man is a stand-up he's a
comedian uh well guys send in the Super
Chat send in the paypals tell us what
you think think we've got another
article we're going to read about the
impact of this on the American